-Higgins, I know that you
find math boring.
-Yeah.
-Well, that's why I've taken --
I've updated math
to make the equations
be about stuff
that you can relate to.
-Oh!
-Yeah, it's a new segment
called "Popular Mathematics."
Here we go.
-♪ Popular mathematics ♪
♪ Mathematics ♪
-This is new?
A new segment?
-It's new to some -- some eyes.
-Okay, sure.
-Let's take a look
at our first equation here.
If you take Shrek...
-Yeah.
-...okay, plus a Peloton...
-...it equals
the Jolly Green Giant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Are you understanding?
-No.
-You're not understanding.
Yeah, I'll give you another one.
I'll give you another example.
You take a Labradoodle...
-Yeah.
-...plus an electric razor,
it equals Rand Paul.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Are you understanding math?
-Not yet.
-Yeah, I'm trying
to help you out.
Let me give you another example.
If you take "Wheel of Fortune"
minus the wheel,
minus Vanna White,
minus Pat Sajak,
minus the audience, plus Wi-Fi,
it equals Wordle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ohhh!
-Let me --
Here's another example.
If you take high school
minus homework plus ecstasy,
it equals "Euphoria."
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
-You understand.
-That I understand.
-That one, you --
If you take Shaq...
-Shaq.
-...plus Kevin Hart,
plus telling the dentist
you floss every single day,
it equals "Big Little Lies."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's another one.
You'll get this one.
-Maybe.
-Chris Evans plus Tina Fey
plus getting something
off a high shelf
equals Christina Ricci.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Christina reaching.
-Yeah.
If you take Christmas
minus decorations, minus fun,
plus overpriced candy
equals Valentine's Day.
[ Laughter and applause ]
My jam's Whitman's Sampler.
-Ooh, yeah.
-That's my jam right there.
'Cause then you do all the thing
and the candies are all good,
and you go, "Yeah,"
and then it's a secret floor,
a secret bottom.
-Right, you open up --
-You open up and you have
a whole nother Valentine's Day.
[ Laughter ]
How about this example?
If you take Buddhism...
-Mm-hmm.
-...plus vegan cheese...
-Vegan cheese. Okay.
-...yeah, it equals Zendaya.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, if you take the
Olympic logo plus an emo phase,
it equals the Audi logo.
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Popular Mathematics."